welcome back to CBS News live coverage
of the royal wedding of Prince Harry and
Megan Marco I'm Gayle King Kevin Frazier
you know from Entertainment Tonight we
are partners today yes we've got the
best location we think we're right
outside look Kevin Windsor Castle is
right there right there spectacular
you're hearing Windsor England and just
moments ago British Prime Minister
Theresa May treated this my very best
wishes to Prince Harry and Megan Markel
on their wedding day to all of those
joining the national celebration with
speed parties and other events have a
wonderful day
Thank You Teresa Mary very nice so many
folks getting on social media this
morning Serena Williams was on Instagram
she what she's getting ready for the
wedding that is why this is probably the
hottest ticket on the planet earth right
now only about 600 guests will be inside
st. George's Chapel and attending the
lunchtime reception only about 200 will
be at the evening reception hosted by
Prince Charles at Frogmore house I got
something about that tell me about that
I know that James Corden who's also
coming to a wedding has been asked to
host the evening so he's going to be in
charge of the entertainment putting the
program together tonight
that's very cool James Corden it it
should be a very good night Mark
Phillips is watching this carefully and
selected audience make its way in he is
inside the grounds right now mark any
famous faces so far
well they're starting to show up but you
may think you have the best perspective
don't take it personally but this is the
best perspective on the wedding right
outside of us in George's Chapel where
we're now seeing in fact the first of
the guests to arrive you don't just rock
up at a wedding like this there's a
whole protocol and a whole security
thing happening the guests for the
chapel go to an assembly point elsewhere
in town they cleared through security
themselves then they're bused here to
the chapel where they're now arriving
you mentioned the Serena Williams she
tweeted since this morning from her
bathroom apparently wrapped in a towel
that she was preparing to come here
perhaps the TMI tweet some other people
you might not know but who are also
coming Priyanka Chopra and it's an
Indian actress who commented you're
seeing now of course Hollywood royalty
perhaps people almost better known than
the Queen it George Clooney and his wife
Amal are also on the guest list here
from suits also from showbiz the entire
cast are very close to it we'll be here
including Patrick Adams who is her
on-screen husband famously married in
the last episode on screen of that show
and they tweeted a shot and there they
are at a dinner in London last night so
quite a lot of suits not wearing suits
here in London before this this is all
part of the build up the arrival of the
guests now the times getting close but
this is something that has been going on
in fact since before dawn this morning
dawn over Windsor and it's tempting to
talk of the dawn of a new era although
new eras quickly start to look like old
eras where the Royals are concerned even
with the modern variations promised
today there's a tried and tested formula
to these things the truly dedicated have
been camping out all night on the
streets of Windsor staking their claim
to their patch of freezing sidewalk I'm
freezing cold my back is sore and I just
want to go to bed
the groom and best man Prince's Harry
and William made their requisite foray
into the crowd yesterday afternoon it's
one of the ways the modern Royals try to
stay in touch with their admirers and it
works
Megan Markel and her mother made only a
brief appearance at the hotel they're
staying out of a 20 minutes away
Doria Raglan met the Queen yesterday and
will accompany her daughter to the
chapel and tens of thousands have begun
to arrive in the town of Windsor just to
be here and to catch a glimpse of but by
then married couple as they take a
carriage ride through the town after the
ceremony before heading back to her
reception and of course guests still
arriving here we're also waiting to see
we anticipate that remember the Spice
Girls some of them will be here
the Beckham's of course they will be
here as well Kevin it's kind of a who's
who of friends and associates of Megan
Markel and of course pretory the new
Duchess to Sutton's
all right thank you very much mark but I
must know this who's your favorite Spice
Girl posh spice spice who is it
sporty sporty sport a very good forty
Mark Phillips is your favorite funny
ginger ginger as well Jared that's so
good thank you very much mark thanks